Speaker 1: We, over the last few years, there's
been sort of a almost like a cultural battle
around the FBI and intelligence agencies.
The FBI, much maligned by Donald Trump and
Trumpists for its allegedly politically biased
involvement in electoral politics.
Even though if you actually think back to
2016, the FBI's involvement may have been
what handed Donald Trump a victory.
Remember James Comey's second completely unnecessary
press conference about the investigation into
Hillary Clinton's emails?
But let's put that aside for now.
Modern day we have seen the FBI become a flashpoint
of controversy, particularly in the context
of the Jan. six riots.
There is now a blockbuster new investigation
from The Washington Post, which shows that
actually the FBI received very specific tips
about the violence that was expected to happen
on January 6th, which did remember the day
of the Trump riots.
But the FBI, as far as the Washington Post
has uncovered, declined to act.
This is stunning.
Let's look at some of the information.
A sprawling new investigation by The Washington
Post into the events leading up to the Capitol
insurrection has revealed that the FBI received
numerous and highly detailed tips on the potential
for serious violence by followers of then-President
Donald Trump on January six.
And despite the specificity and volume of
reports, the FBI largely dismissed the warnings.
The fact that law enforcement of all stripes
reportedly underestimated the likelihood of
violence on January six has already been widely
reported, but the Post's massive project started
last spring.
Based on interviews of more than 230 people,
describes in excruciating detail just how
much was ignored.
In one of the more shocking revelations, the
Post recounts how information began flooding
in to the FBI as early as December six, when
the agency received a tip about a message
in an online post telling Trump supporters,
Please be in D.C. armed on the six, you might
have to kill the palace guards.
Are you OK with that?
And indeed, there was violence against the
so-called palace guards U.S. Capitol Police
there to defend the Capitol.
Another message reported by the Post stated
in an apparent reference to killing officers
drop a handful.
The rest will flee, meaning kill a few US
Capitol Police, and then they're going to
get out of our way.
On Dec. 19, Trump tweeted a message exhorting
his followers to come to DC on January six,
writing quote big protest in D.C. on January
six.
There will be wild.
That lit up online.
Pro-Trump groups and FBI informants quickly
began passing on information about highly
specific planning for a violent attack in
Washington.
Here's how the Post puts it.
The FBI received a call alerting them to Trump
supporters, making plans online to bring arms
to Washington and arrest lawmakers that the
Sunday afternoon call was handled by the bureau's
National Threat Operation Center, a clearinghouse
for tips about crimes, according to a document
titled Threats to Take Guns and overrun the
D.C. police Jan. four to January 20th.
It's almost like the 911 memo bin Laden poised
to strike threats to take guns and overrun
D.C. police.
The file was updated the following afternoon
by an FBI employee seeking to reclassify the
information more domestic terrorism than criminal
in nature.
They wanted to say, Hey, this is almost not
even just criminal.
This is domestic terrorism.
Criminal has received a number of guardians
as a significant number of guardians as a
result of threats to Congress and other government
officials.
The caller, according to the FBI document,
said people were planning on meeting in certain
areas and sneaking guns into D.C. in an attempt
to overrun the D.C. police.
Beginning January 4th through 20th on three
different sites, there is discussion about
recruitment, where to meet at, bring guns
and arresting senators and members of Congress
to hold trials outside in public areas in
one specific threat.
Utah Republican Senator Mitt Romney, often
regarded by Trump supporters as a traitor
to MAGA, was named as a.
Target, yet despite all of this, on December
22nd, the Post says the FBI closed its internal
threat assessment of the matter, determining
it did not warrant further investigation at
this time.
An FBI official told the Post that before
doing so, steps were taken to share the info,
but ultimately the determination was made
that the tips they received featured vague
and primarily First Amendment protected speech.
When we think back and we say, how were they
not more ready and why was the National Guard
not deployed in advance?
And even as the capital was being overrun
and as we follow the chain of command upward,
we learned that on the day of it was Donald
Trump who was reportedly gleefully watching
the first couple of hours of the riots, maybe
thinking it would actually prevent Joe Biden
from ultimately being certified as president
of the United States.
Later, Trump started to not really like that.
The rioters looked low class and made him
look bad.
But the pressure was building for him to deploy
the National Guard.
He was told Mike Pence is potentially in danger.
Mike Pence had to be evacuated.
They were chanting, Hang Mike Pence.
But we know that Trump was actually mad at
Mike Pence.
Trump was furious that Pence wasn't willing
to do what Trump believed Pence could do to
really stop the certification of Joe Biden
as president, even though Pence accurately
told them, I can't do that, sir, I can't do
that.
And the calls built for Trump to call off
the protesters and to send in the National
Guard.
And it was Trump who resisted doing that on
January 6th.
But this is a much broader back story of a
sort of hot potato that was being played behind
the scenes.
The FBI was at the time that they could say
this is criminal, not domestic terrorism,
sort of letting the D.C. police know you might
want to do something about this.
The FBI was saying to Department of Justice,
You know, maybe you need to look into this
and coordinate fencing or whatever the case
may be of Capitol Hill.
Police seemed not to actually even be told
what the FBI was aware of.
And then there was this last minute request
for National Guard, which was initially resisted,
although ultimately the National Guard was
deployed.
And there are some people who are writing
this is just like what happened on 9-11, where
agencies couldn't communicate, they couldn't
coordinate.
There weren't systems in place, but this is
actually a clearly different thing after 911
systems were put in place so that different
agencies could coordinate with each other.
This seems more that there was a lack of willingness
to do those things for reasons we don't yet
totally know.
And possibly because somebody ordered them
to stand down.
So let's I will now explain to you the more
benign explanation and then the really horrible
one, the more benign explanation here is the
FBI genuinely didn't think that there was
the potential for Jan. six to become what
it was.
And they made a mistake in judgment.
They didn't take it seriously enough.
Now what's interesting about that is that
it would sort of run counter to the idea that
the FBI and all of these intel agencies and
others were out there to make Trump look as
bad as possible and all these different things.
It sounds like, you know, if the FBI wanted
to make Trump really bad, they would have
publicized this in advance.
They would have made Trump look bad, etc.
They didn't do that.
The sort of sinister possibility for which
we don't yet have evidence right there.
These are the speculative ideas is that someone
once they caught wind, that the FBI was receiving
these threats, information about these threats
and starting to act on them, someone told
the FBI.
Stand down.
Turn this over to someone else, sort of, but
don't really give a much information because
we want the riots to be able to happen because
we think maybe they actually will stop the
certification of the election.
We don't know the answer to that yet, but
every week we are getting more and more information
about the fact that many people and by people,
we mean elected officials, associates of Trump
and law enforcement had reason to fear that
this was going to get really, really bad on
January six.
And it did, and the right preparations were
not ultimately in place at some point.
We may know the full story.
We still don't know it as of right now.